Have you ever noticed that no matter how
much context that you give your LLM, the
outputs are never truly the same? And in
fact, they can tend to get worse the
longer that you chat with it. And
Enthropic has just released Claude
Skills, which is designed to solve just
that. In this video, I'm going to
explain to you what Claude skills are in
a non-technical way so you can actually
understand them. The crucial difference
between skills and cloud projects
that'll save you thousands of tokens,
and five plug-and-play business use
cases that'll save you dozens of hours.
Okay. So, what exactly are Claude
skills? Think of Claude skills of having
like a personal recipe book for your AI.
Without skills, every time that you want
Claude to do something specific like
format a report a certain way or follow
your brand guidelines, you have to give
it the full instructions every single
time. And more complex your instructions
become, the more tokens that you need to
accomplish whatever it is that you want
to do. This is why your output starts
degrading over time. With Claude skills,
also known as agent skills in Claude,
you write down the recipe once, then
whenever you need it, Claude just pulls
up that recipe and then follows it
perfectly. No reexplaining, no copying
and pasting the same instructions over
and over. And here's the really clever
bit. Claude doesn't load every recipe at
once. It only opens the cookbook, if you
will, to the page that it needs when it
needs it. This means faster responses
and better results because it's focused
on exactly what it is that you are
asking for. The technical term for this
is called progressive disclosure, which
means Claude is loading information in
stages as it's needed rather than
consuming all of your context up front.
Now, let's go into Claude and I'll show
you exactly where to start accessing
skills. But before we do that, if you're
new here, my name is Rick Mul already
and for the past almost 12 years now,
I've run a seven-figure online business
helping other online business owners
grow and scale their online business.
Today, I run an AI community called the
AI playbook where I help online business
owners leverage AI so that you can
become more efficient, streamline your
business, and increase profitability in
your business. I'll link to the AI
playbook community in the description
below. Would love to see you in there.
Okay, so you can access Cloud Skills in
the web version, in the desktop version,
and the API in Cloud Code. We're looking
at the web version right now. So, you're
going to go down to your little initials
in the bottom lefthand corner, click on
settings, and then you'll click on
capabilities. And if you scroll down
here a little bit, you're going to see
skills. These are going to be defaulted
to off. Claude is going to use these
automatically. You don't have to set
anything up. These are already
pre-built. You just flip them on based
on whichever ones that you want to do.
We're going to look today at the brand
guidelines one. And the other option is
to create your own skill, which again
we're going to talk about more here in
just a second. You just click on upload
skill and then you can upload it right
here and you will see it in your list
much like I've done here with the
YouTube growth engine skill. And by the
way, to access skills, you are going to
need to be on a paid claude plan. And
also another important note, custom
skills right now are individual to each
user, which means if you're on a team
plan or an enterprise plan, they're not
shared organizationwide. Now, you might
be wondering, Rick, I already use cloud
projects. What's the difference? Cloud
projects are persistent context
containers, if you will. When you create
a project, you're essentially saying,
every conversation in this space should
know X about me or my business. projects
are going to be best for ongoing work
with consistent context. Like for
example, if you're working on content
creation for your business and you need
Claude to reference specific docs
repeatedly, Claude Project Cloud skills
on the other hand are executable
capabilities, if you will. They're
specialized tools that Claude can invoke
or use to perform specific tasks all by
itself. Think of them like a plug-in or
mini apps. and skills are reusable
across any conversation and you can use
them within cloud projects. So here's a
practical framework for thinking about
this. Use a cloud project when claude
needs to know your brand voice or your
ICP for every single chat. Use a cloud
skill on the other hand when you want a
repeatable workflow like YouTube content
creation or when you need to create
specific file types and you want to
update those files dynamically as you
are using them. The key is does it
follow a specific workflow with clear
inputs, steps, and outputs? That's a
skill. Is it ongoing context that Claude
needs to remember in a specific place?
That's a Claude project. Right. Now,
let's talk about how agent skills are
structured. Remember agent skills,
claude skills, same thing. Let me show
you the anatomy of a skill so that you
understand how to build one. And the
first thing to understand is that every
skill is going to require a skill.md
file. So, it's a markdown file with YAML
front matter. If you were like, "What
are you talking about, Rick?" All that
means is at the top of your file, you're
going to define the name of the skill
and the description of what the skill
does and when to use it. Then after
that, you're going to want to provide
clear step-by-step instructions for
Claude to follow, plus, if applicable,
any concrete examples. You're also going
to want to have a folder if necessary.
In this case here, a folder for logos
and additional fonts. Well, those are
going to be in either one or maybe two
additional files. So, here's an example
of what the structure of your skill
might look like. So, you're going to
have a folder with all of these
resources for the skill in that folder.
So, you're going to have the skill.md
like I just talked about, and then
you're going to have additional folders
with different resources. Maybe you
might have a folder for the logo files.
You might have a folder for the font
files. You might have a folder for
examples, so showing us examples. You
might have a folder that contains your
writing style or your tone of voice or
what have you. And here's a tip. Only
add context that Claude doesn't already
have. The key here is being lean and
keeping it as simple as possible. All
right, now that you got the foundational
knowledge of Claude skills, let's talk
about five mind-blowing use cases where
skills really shine. Hey, for the first
use case, I want to show you how easy it
is to use one of the pre-made skills
that Anthropic has included here in
Claude. So, again, I'm going to go down
to settings. I'm going to go to
capabilities and then go down here. I
want to make sure that the brand
guidelines skill is turned on. And if
you click these three little dots here,
we're going to say try in chat. And it's
going to give us this little message
here. I just added the brand guidelines
skill. Can you make something amazing
with it? I'm going to click go. And
let's see what it comes back with. All
right, cool. So, it came back and told
me it's an example skill that applies
Anthropics brand colors. I don't care
about their brand colors. So, I'm going
to say I want to create my own custom
brand guidelines skill for the AI
playbook. It's creating comprehensive
brand guidelines, replacing the template
with my AI playbook brand standards. And
you'll notice here, by the way, that the
first file that it's creating is that
skill.md file, which again is the name
of the skill, the description of the
skill, and then the instructions for how
to use the skill. All right, it's just
wrapped up here. Took a few minutes to
do it, but really, really well done.
It's created my brand guidelines skill
for me, which is the downloadable file
right here. It tells me what the brand
identity it used. All that is correct.
It created the uh brand demo PowerPoint
slides for me. It created the readme
file uh for a markdown file to include
in the skill. And then here are all the
skill files that it gave me. So I can
click on download now. And for the AI
playbook brand skill, I can then go into
I can click on upload skill upload. I
just did this and you'll see it right
here. So, anytime I want to create like
PowerPoint slides or visual materials or
whatever inside of Claude, I can just
tell it to use my brand guidelines
because I've created this skill. It will
do it the same way every single time
that align with my brand. Okay, for use
case number two, let's create a lead
scoring calculator skill. Imagine you've
got a pile of leads and you need to
prioritize who to follow up with first.
So, we're going to create a skill that
takes your lead list and automatically
generates an Excel spreadsheet that
scores and ranks them based on
customizable criteria that you set. The
skill will ask for your leads and
scoring criteria or use intelligent
defaults like company size, budgets,
engagement level, etc. It'll then output
an Excel file with individual scores,
total scores, priority rankings, and
even conditional formatting with green,
for example, for for hot leads, yellow
for warm, and red for cold. Okay? And
here's the prompt I'm going to use. And
just by the first sentence here, I'm
telling Claw, create a skill called lead
scoring calculator that does the
following. And I've given it very
explicit things that I want it to do.
All right. In less than 2 minutes, it's
created the skill for me and it's
outlined exactly what's included in the
skill. Now, let's test it with our lead
data. All right, so I just put in a
sample of five leads with a whole bunch
of data about those leads to test the
skill. And you can see here as it's
going through and processing my request,
it's going through each of the only the
necessary files within the skill. So,
it's first referring to this skill.md
file because that has the instructions
on basically how to use the skill, but
then it's only going to pull from the
necessary resources that it needs like I
talked about before. And here you can
see that it's creating the lead scoring
spreadsheet for me. All right, here it's
giving me the priorities using the
colors that I asked it to and a summary.
And then here is my spreadsheet over
here in a new artifact. And by the way,
just to note, this is actually a really
important distinction. When you are
creating skills this way on the web
version, any files that Claude's
creating for you as part of the skill,
they're not being stored locally on your
machine. They're being stored virtually
in Claude temp files. You can get more
advanced with it and create skills that
connect to files actually on your
computer. We talk a lot more about that,
go a lot more in depth in my AI playbook
community if you want to get into
creating slightly more advanced style
skills. For use case number three, let's
just say that you finish a client
project and then they want a report.
Normally, you're going to be spending
like two, three, even more hours pulling
data, copying metrics into a document,
formatting it to look all professional.
Instead, with a skill, let's just say
that you've got a folder with files for
your project data, your metrics, your
notes, and then you can just trigger the
client report builder skill that I'm
going to show you how to create. tell it
the folder path where that information
lives, the client name, and the report
date, and then it's going to create a
complete report for you. Okay, so I'm
just going to paste in the prompt that I
want to use to create the client report
builder skill. And again, I'm telling it
create a skill. And as you can see, the
first file it's creating is the
skill.md. So again, this is these are
the instructions for the skill and how
to execute the skill for itself. Okay,
it's gone ahead and created the client
report builder skill. And now, let's
test it out. So, I'm just telling it use
the client report builder skill to
generate a report. And here's the report
that this skill just created for me. You
can see the cover page, executive
summary, project overview, results in
metric, client feedback,
recommendations, next steps. It's pretty
thorough. And of course, I can customize
this however I want. If I want different
results in my report, I can update the
skill accordingly. That's a great thing
about skills. You can keep iterating on
it and give it feedback and it will
dynamically update the instructions for
you. All right, for use case number
four, this is what I call my strategic
decision-making skill. Create a skill
that walks you through your
decision-making framework. So for me,
for example, first principles, 8020
analysis, systems thinking, jobs to be
done for any business decision. So for
example, when creating your skill, you
can bundle your framework templates, you
know, example analyses of decisions
based on these frameworks, a decision
documentation format in the skill if you
want. So now when you have a vague
problem or something that you want to
make a decision on, you activate the
skill and it's going to guide you
through a very structured analysis with
a clear recommendation. It's like having
a strategic consultant available 24/7
for you. And for me, here's what that
skill looks like. This is the skill.md
file which is explaining again name of
the skill, the description of the skill,
and then all the necessary information
in terms of the frameworks etc. So now
we can test this out. This is something
I'm considering in the business.
Actually going to do this. I'm going to
test this out. I'm considering adding a
higher tier to my AI playbook community.
It will be $997
a month. What do you think? So, you can
see here that it is analyzing the
different decision-m frameworks against
the question that I've asked it. And now
it's breaking down my question through
each of these principles. And then
coming down here, it's giving me its
specific analysis. And for use case
number five, a super helpful skill to
create is a survey data analyzer skill.
So, let's say you send out a survey in
your business, you get 40 or multiple
hundreds of responses. Now, you're
staring at a spreadsheet with hundreds
of cells of text in it and data. I mean,
it's going to take you hours to go
through and analyze it. Let me show you
a better way. So, I've given it my
prompt for exactly what I want this
survey data analyzer skill to do. Okay,
so it's built the skill for me and I
want to test it now with actual survey
results from my AI playbook members and
I just want to tell it to proceed. Okay,
now using our skill, Claude has just
analyzed our survey responses and given
me the stats, average rating, NPS, and
then it generated a bunch of files for
me. So, it generated a 7page executive
summary with an analysis, created an
Excel document with four different tabs,
rating distribution, wordcloud data,
created a PDF for me with numbers and
key findings, and then finally created a
10 slide PowerPoint presentation for me.
I mean, once we've created the skill, it
took a matter of what, 5 minutes to
actually run the skill. Now, next time
when you have survey results and you
have this skill, all you have to do is
attach your CSV file or tell it where it
is on your on your computer and say, I
want you to analyze these survey results
for me and it will run the skill for you
and give you this kind of level output.
Here's what all this really means.
skills let you package your expertise,
your processes, your frameworks into
reusable tools that Claude can execute
consistently every single time. I'm
really impressed with Claude skills and
how they're able to help me and make
things way way easier in my business.
Again, if you're an online business
owner and you're looking to leverage AI
more deeply in your business, you're
looking to streamline, make it more
efficient, make more money with AI in
your business, and also increase
profitability, I want to invite you to
join us inside my AI playbook community,
which I'll link to in the description
below. As always, thanks so much for
watching today's video. I'll see you in
the next one.